ambrosi y es un barrio los suburbios del
sur de beirut
aquí es donde creció que hacen mawla
este empleado portuario perdió la vida
el 4 de agosto del 2020 cuando 2.700
toneladas de nitrato de amonio arrasaron
parte de la capital libanesa
su padre joseph recuerda aquella
terrible noche que pasó buscando a su
hijo
recorrimos los hospitales fui a ver a
los heridos estaba en las morgues
incluso examines restos humanos para ver
si eran los restos de mi hijo no deseo
que nadie vea lo que dije oferten de su
estado con salud la majada de su casa
tenía 26 años el día de la tragedia a su
madre amalia sólo le quedan algunas
fotos como recuerdo
recuerdo a mi hijo cuando era pequeño lo
abrazaba le cantaba para que se durmiera
lo alimentaba espero que dios no los
perdone ahora sus fotos están colgadas
por todas partes sólo quedan las fotos
de qué sirve tener solo fotos para la
investigación sobre este desastre sigue
abierta pero joseph de mí que la clase
política esté obstruyendo el proceso
el malo
a todo diputado o ministro cuyo nombre
se mencione deberá comparecer y su
inmunidad deberá ser levantada desde el
momento en que sea interrogado aparecerá
no como testigo sino como acusa al fayed
un año después de las explosiones y
usted y amable viven con el temor de
nunca saber verdaderamente qué pasó
aseguran que seguirán luchando a pesar
de todo para que se haga justicia para
su hijo y para las demás víctimas